they levitate so if you put a magnet on
top of a superconductor it levitates and
this is quantum emergence in
[Music]
action so I'm going to talk about um
something I term quantum emergence so
what is emergence it's also something
you might have heard in other areas not
just uh physics it essentially relates
to Collective ensembles of objects
collectively self assembling to form
something very very different from the
individual
constituents um and you can think about
um people in crowds so the collective
behaves very differently from each
individual member you can think about
something like
Consciousness it would be very
far-fetched to think of Consciousness in
terms of individual neurons in cutting
up the brain and saying okay what are
the individual elements that make it up
and somehow I'm going to add them
together and arrive at the functioning
of the brain and Consciousness it's
almost as absurd it is as absurd to
think about materials that are all
around us that are made up of trillion
trillions of electrons and imagine that
the collective self-organized processes
that emerge from them which are as
complex and as exotic as Consciousness
to be in some way derivable from A
reduced equation of individual electrons
so instead um how I think of it is for
instance this is um a painting from mcer
so at one end you can think about this
as individual electrons where you have
the birds which are not really
interacting with each other as you
increase the extent of interaction
between the electrons by the end it ends
up looking like buildings so at this
point it has no connection with what it
started out with you can't start with
whatever this new Collective
self-organized entity that is formed
with and say I'm going to be able to
explain it in terms of what we started
with uh my initial starting point is
this reductionist approach is not
something that works for emerging
systems um and this is just an example
of one of the very exotic forms of
emergent phenomena which is
superconductivity so this is a
superconducting material which I I'll
tell you about in a bit H sorry these uh
the the puck is the superconducting
material and this is a string of magnets
so essentially what you see happening
here you can see this is
levitation so super conducting materials
have a couple of really interesting
properties firstly they conduct
electricity perfectly without any loss
and this is a dramatic Quantum property
and I'll show you an example in a bit
and the second is that they levitate so
if you put a magnet on top of a
superconductor it levitates and this is
quantum emergence in action if you took
a single electron or a few electrons you
would not get super conductivity it
would not be predicted from the model
the way super conductivity was
discovered is at first people took
materials um cooled them down to very
very low temperatures discovered that
they lost all resistance to the flow of
electricity that there was this amazing
uh property of levitation
so it was an experimental Discovery and
then they worked backward and said okay
how can we form a model that now
explains this um so emergent phenomena
are as exotic as this and uh this is
again an example of the applications of
superconductivity so um an MRI machine
where you put your head into and have an
MRI done that's a superconducting magnet
so these aren't just exotic phenomena in
a laboratory they're applied and the
giant ring so you might have be familiar
with the CERN experiment so there's a
large ring that's um I believe 18 miles
uh in circumference that's a giant
superconducting magnet so every electron
any point in this is perfectly
correlated with every other electron
this is a collective self-organized
effect these electrons don't bump into
each other like in regular metals they
all form a giant Quantum wave which has
the property of what you saw that
electricity would flow perfectly through
such a large loop in this case it's a
superconducting magnet which channels
the electrons which accelerates them as
they go through so this is just one
example of an emergent phenomena so what
I try to do is to discover new emergent
Quantum phenomena and so starting from
the claim that a reductionist approach
is not the way to start I wouldn't start
of it imagining it as Lego blocks I
think often uh physicists like to think
of models in which we say okay we
understand how one thing behaves let's
break it down to the most fundamental
particle like these little Lego pieces
and from there we can build whatever we
want so we can dial up a phenomena so
start with individual fundamental
particles and we can build material
Quantum matter that isn't really how it
works and this is because as I told you
we have trillion trillion electron
it's much more like thinking of this is
just um a comparison for fun this is a
rat's brain with 100 billion neurons
this is a universe with aund 100 billion
galaxies this is just to give you an
idea this is not even trillion trillion
this is an order of magnitude less
that's the level of complexity we're
dealing with so we deal with them much
more like entangled complex systems not
like Lego blocks so of course the
question is this is all well and good
but if I wanted to discover a new
Quantum phase of matter how would I do
that given this uh level of complexity
and this is where what I call Quantum
Alchemy comes into play and essentially
what I mean by Quantum Alchemy is one
Quantum phase of matter transforming
into another quantum phase of matter so
rather than start with Lego blocks build
them up and say uh well hope I get a new
Quantum phase I start with an exist
phase of matter that's quite ordinary or
mundane so just to um um give you a
concept of what phases are it's a little
bit like water ice and steam right
they're made up of the same constituent
um atoms but at different temperatures
they transform so water boils becomes
steam water melts become becomes ice
Quantum phases are a little bit like
that except they're uh entangled in in
much more profound ways and they're at
low temp temperatures but it's a similar
idea of one phase transforming into the
other so what I Look to do is start with
a more conventional phase of matter say
start with a magnet something that's
ubiquitous and through a process that
I'll describe at the moment experiment
on it and look to transform its
properties into another quantum phase
with exotic unconventional unknown
unimagined properties and so the
starting point is this is this is a uh
cartoon or schematic so I start with one
phase of matter here which is known and
go through this point of
discontinuity and this is where for
example water boiling into steam there's
a point of discontinuity which is a
boiling point where there's maximal
chaos there's maximally large
fluctuations the entire system is
turbulent and then it swaps into the
other phase and that region of maximal
chaos is where I Look to experimentally
study and in the quantum world not just
is there maximal chaos and turbulence
but new phases of matter emerge there so
experimentally this is the region I
tried to access this region of uh
instability of discontinuity or Quantum
phase transition and empirically and
phenomenologically what uh we've found
is that this is like a portal to a new
region of quantum phase space so this is
where if you experimentally approach it
doesn't just swap into the other phase
it doesn't become a combination of these
an entirely new phase emerges it's like
opening a portal to a new universe so
the experimental tools I use um so this
is what I actually do in the laboratory
I go to very cold temperatures so um
down to lower than- 270° C so a few
Melvin so very close to absolute zero
where Quantum effects are maximal I work
with diamonds so I should have had a
scale on there so this tip so this is a
um a coin so this tip is about 100
microns so um not too much bigger than a
human hair so this is like a tip of a
stiletto heel exerts pressure so the tip
of a diamond you exert much more
pressure almost as much pressure at the
Earth's course so that's where you can
transform materials um and the third
experimental tool I use is very high
magnets so th this is a very big magnet
um which which is 45 Tesla strong that's
about 10,000 times as strong as a magnet
on your fridge so this is a very very
high magnetic field this is me and my
research group we traveled to Florida to
use these high field uh magnets so
essentially I take a material that is
well known that it's it's in a phase
that we understand and I apply low
temperatures high pressures and high
magnetic fields to take it to that point
of transition instability
and look to see how its properties
transform it's almost like entering a
new materials universe so the universe
we're in we can't go and change its
conditions and say I'll just turn up the
temperature a little bit I'll change the
atmosphere just as well life wouldn't
exist if we did that but I can take a
crystal of a material with these with
this whole universe of electrons in it
change the conditions and it's like
changing the universe and creating a new
phase so this is the only data slide I'm
going to show uh this is we start with a
magnets so these were experiments we did
when we created a super conductor so we
started with a magnet um its transition
temperature
is-50 um that's not important so you
apply pressure to it so we applied
pressure it became less and less good a
magnet and at some point before it died
so before it reached that Quantum
transition where there's maximum chaos
this superconducting phase appeared so
what started out not as a superconductor
is quite a commonplace magnet at not
even conducting electricity very well by
changing the conditions all we did was
change the conditions and discovered a
new phase emerg we've entered a new
phase which is now superc conductivity
so this is an example of how I use
quantum Alchemy or what I term quantum
Alchemy to transform a material into a
Noel Quantum phase of matter
and these are techniques I used to
discover um similarly more exotic more
unconventional uh phases of matter and
the next step is so superconductors are
already known and um as I mentioned they
used in MRI in CERN they can be used for
instance in um electric motors in
electric aircraft they can be made very
light and the levitation uh makes it
possible to create a motor without Bowl
bearings without friction so they used
uh to make electric aircrafts possible
by aircraft Airbus and Boeing they can
be used in superconducting chips so the
applications are clearly um profound and
this is just for superc conductivity
there's many other exotic Quantum phases
and just something that I I'd like to
leave you um with is this thought that
mapping out a space of um Quantum phases
and actually mapping out physical
phenomena in general is not about a
finite space of knowledge and somehow
we're chipping away at some point we're
going to arrive at a theory of
everything and we can explain everything
and we'll be done it's much more like an
infinite universe so each time this is
this is a mandle bradet this is just a
schematic of a fractal and what this is
just capturing is that each time you get
to the end of a known phase another one
starts so I showed you the example of a
magnet ending with a superconductor but
it's infinite it's an open system that
has no end so each time you make a
discovery you enter a portal into a new
phase that's the beginning of a new
Infinity so you have infinitely
branching Infinities um and there's a
really nice quote from lucretius from BC
actually so uh this is a you know
ancient um quotation and so he's talking
about there's no lack of borders but
rather an infinite proliferation of them
everything is bounded by something else
without any absolute limitation from
outside nature is not a boundless Unity
but an infinitely limited multiplicity
of limits without a fixed absolute limit
in other words everything in nature
moves even its limits and that's really
the thought that um I'd like to leave
you with and that drives how we
experiment that we're not reaching some
finite end but it's an infinite voyage
of Discovery um and this is just um H
sort of yeah image to leave you with
what appears like turbulence when this
is taking off you can see the patterns
emerging and the organizing emerging
where what looks like chaos and
turbulence is actually a new
formation thank you to continue watching
this video click the link on the top
left or in the description below or
visit I.V for more debates and talks
from the world's leading thinkers on
today's biggest
ideas